also developing abroad tonight us the uk
israel yep all saying iran attacked an
israeli-managed tanker
raising more questions about what will
the biden administration strategy for
confronting an increasing hostile
iranian regime
besides forcing south korea to give them
seven billion dollars
as they now enrich more uranium than
ever and will biden
ever hold the communist chinese
government accountable not only for the
virus
but their threats of attacks against oh
american military bases japanese
military bases
their attacks against pro-democracy
protesters in
hong kong oh and of course their
claim of reunification with taiwan
joining us now with more fox news
contributors former secretary of state
mike pompeo
let me first start with the virus
they're not held accountable we
now you read these emails now we knew
what this
lab was doing and now we know that
taxpayer dollars went to it
your reaction
yes well we've known since i spoke about
this at least in the spring of 2020
that this virology lab was almost
certainly the place shawn that this
virus came from and we've seen the deep
cover-up right it continues to this day
they won't let anybody in to do the
investigation in a proper way
the chinese communist party is
responsible for allowing people to
travel with a known
very contagious virus one that is very
lethal and they put it across the world
this is incredibly reckless and they've
got to be held accountable
there's lots of ways we could do this it
doesn't appear the byte administration
is going to head down
any of those paths there are many tools
without any further legislation that the
byte administration could use to hold
the chinese communist party accountable
for the millions of deaths around the
world
and the billions of dollars in lost
wealth that resulted from this chinese
voicing of a virus
upon the world something you'd never let
happen
then the chinese are lecturing our
current secretary of state on the issue
of human rights
that's rich i know you would never let
that happen uh
they're threatening u.s military bases
japanese military bases
they're lecturing us about our planes
landing in
taiwan our ally country and they're
talking about reunification with taiwan
uh would that be how you describe uh
uh any military effort in in
the china sea
sean it's not remotely how we approached
making sure that we put real pressure on
the chinese communist party in
particular with
taiwan in our final days we authorized
mq-9 reapers to be sold to the taiwanese
so they could defend their country
we did the same thing with f-16s we made
clear we were going to continue
freedom of navigation efforts up through
the strait
and when the chinese spoke of
reunification well that's just false
it was never part of china and we didn't
allow them to use that language without
confronting it
we have to be serious about these things
sean you know this right when you're
weak
you you beget risk you create real risk
because your your adversaries believe
they can walk all over you when you're
strong
when you're clear about the words you
use and you're prepared to back them up
as the trump administration always was
when you're prepared to back up the
things that will secure american freedom
your adversaries take note of that and
then we see it with putin don't we with
the the ratcheted up cyber attacks
uh with his territorial ambitions with a
greater military presence on the border
with ukraine
um and what we reward putin with a
summit
we will reward putin with a waiver so we
can build the pipeline while we cancel
our pipeline
we force our allies south korea to give
7 billion to the iranian muellers as
they
are enriching more uranium than ever and
involved in these attacks against israel
i'm concerned overall mr secretary i've
never seen it this bad
nor have i seen our enemies and enemy
states more emboldened
well you began with the discussion sean
about vladimir putin in the summit and
the pipeline those
those were clear indicators that we
weren't going to confront russia in the
same way that our administration did
and the others noted right whether it's
chairman kim in north korea or it's
xi xingping and china they can see
weakness and they will they will
literally try to drive a truck through
it
and you you began the the moment with
the talk about iran
right they they've now killed a brit
killed a romanian
attacked a ship at sea they've launched
rockets through their proxy hamas
into israel from the gaza strip and
we're still sitting at the table trying
to negotiate a nuclear deal with him
this is crazy it's insane uh
yeah we need the adults back in power uh
because i know you wouldn't
do any of these things or allow any of
these things to be happening
nor would president trump thank you we
appreciate it mr secretary
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else